hey guys my name is Jess McDonald and
today it is the 11th of January thanks
so much to marion co for kicking off
games but news for the year last week
and here's what mattered in gaming today
GTA 5 los santos certainly is the crime
infested open-world that keeps on giving
and what it was offering up today with a
brand new way to cause destruction
twitter user karma ingram discovered
that calling one triple 936 737 six
seven on the endgame phone triggers and
explosion and changes the appearance of
stead in game phone kotaku have tested
the feature and come up with rather
satisfying exploded results the secret
revelation has burdened some people to
mine out the games other undiscovered
easter eggs meanwhile the ps4 service
for grand theft auto online are
currently unavailable no reason is given
for the downtime although the GTA or
service status page acknowledges there
is currently limited online gameplay
functionality center forex red announced
that the witcher 3 is 1.1 to patch will
be coming out today on xbox one ps4 and
pc the update was confirmed by community
manager marcin mullet on twitter the
patch notes for the update indicate that
it will fix a number of bugs for the
main game and the hearts of stone
expansion in addition to providing
improvements to general game performance
the witcher threes last patch 1.1 1 was
released in october of last year it
fixed the number of bugs improved
technical performance in some regions
and addressed in new game plus mode
issues things are starting to sound a
little grim for Nathan Drake as
uncharted 4 co-director Neil druckmann
has said that it would be really hard to
have a sequel to uncharted 4 drachman
told the Sun Nathan Drake is at the
height of his popularity so it's not a
good business decision to walk away from
the series but I feel like the best way
to honor him is to go out on top to
finish his story he added that Sony hold
the trademark for uncharted so he can't
speak to where they may take the series
in future although it sounds unlikely
Drake will play a part
he explained with the end of a thief's
end story it will be really hard to do a
sequel with Nathan breaks maybe they'll
be a prequel maybe it will be a
different character I don't know but
this is the end for Nathan Drake
hopefully the reality of the situation
isn't as dire as it sounds let me know
down in the comments if you want to see
more uncharted after this next
installment and in what form you can as
a game spot where we've got stories on
Sony's failed attempts to trademark
let's play and where destiny might be
headed to next that is everything I have
for you today as always let me know what
matters to you and I must be same time
tomorrow